what is up everyone happy thursday
morning it is time for another gratitude
journal live stream number fourteen
welcome back everyone the idea here is
we are doing daily gratitude to stay
happy as entrepreneurs and appreciate
the things that we have in our life it's
something to do with my team and I bring
it to you guys two most important things
is daily it's every day you guys can
join me nine a.m. eastern every day if
you want or do it on your own but it's a
daily thing that we're doing in number
two that you try to feel actually feel
the things that you're good before and
not just list them off but feel it
emotionally because if you want to be
able to get over you know the negative
situations in your life then you have to
make sure that the gratitude that you're
preaching is actually something that
hits you here so how this works I'm
going to share three things I'm grateful
for you guys in a live chat share three
things you're good for I will read them
out once i'm done mine if those are you
watching afterwards leave it down in the
comments below if you do it consistently
i promise you that your life will start
to get happier and better and we need
more happier entrepreneurs in this world
so i'm going to go first I'm I'm
grateful for Alex making me some eggs
this morning so Alex came over he's
working the other room and he made me
these sunny side up egg doesn't what is
sunny-side up he soon as he comes over
he's like oh I just dropped it it's like
God do you have butter mmm so good I'm
grateful for the egg I made a mess so
I'll clean up after I don't get over the
egg um number 2 i'm really grateful for
the day ahead I've got I initially had
nine calls and hang out scheduled I've
got eight now Sony cancel because they
had a cold but I got eight calls and
hangouts today I think it's five
hangouts five live streams this one
league and then three more and then two
calls so basically my whole day
his past except for I think an hour
stretch 45 minutes stretch and I love it
I love it it's like it's not stop it's
full-on it's what I love doing
connecting with different people
entrepreneurs interviews and I'm I I
mean I love wednesdays because I film
but I love Thursday's too because its
meetings and high energy and connect
with others and so super grateful for
the day that is ahead this is the first
of all the live streams but yeah I'm
excited and pumped and hopefully you
guys are joining me on some of them as
we go forward and then number three I'm
really grateful for all the people
who've been reaching out recently wanted
to help me with my book um we're in
crunch time almost it feels like it's
been forever working on this book uh
I've done I want to say seventy weeks of
the Evans book video series so it's been
over a year of doing this a year and a
half because I started writing the book
before I made the video and it's
exciting that it's actually like when
you say December 6 2016 feels like it's
so far away but it's almost october guys
it's almost october i really don't look
forward to the winter coming but i'm
kind of looking forward for december
this is gonna be exciting and then in
the past in the past 24 hours and number
people written in Ryan Holliday who's an
author Chrissy LeBeau who's another
author people at my publishing house
have been right in to say how can we
help try to give advice on the book
launch and so I'm uh I'm grateful for
the support for the ideas for the people
and hopefully it's a it's a successful
lunch because I want to get it into the
hands of as many people as possible just
think it'll make a big difference of
important impact on people's lives so
those are my three what did I have alexs
eggs the day ahead of all the interviews
and other people who've been supporting
me with my book recently I want to get
to you guys we've got five
minutes going to go do some shoutouts
recognize the people in the live chat
and again if you guys watching
afterwards leave yours in the comment
below J reyez thank them for pop culture
and modern stories thank you for
creative business models I love creative
business models thankful for guidance
both internal and external thankful for
clarity of all kinds I like it Zeno Zeno
is back what's the body part of the days
ain't no number one my stomach wait
before the stomach tell me what I really
need to eat something number two
chickens for their meat and eggs eggs
it's a chicken day here emotional growth
number three great for emotional growth
and number four is on the fourth one the
rain I don't know why but I really enjoy
the rain I'm not a big rain fan it's
super cloudy here in Toronto right now
but again the cloudy days help you
appreciate when the Sun does come mahal
Ville number want mahoba you gotta tell
if I'm pronouncing that right because
now you're you're consistently coming
back here I want to make sure i'm
pronouncing your name properly here
mahoba so I'm going with for now at
least but let me know number one people
from the ninth successful day of my
30-day 5am challenge congratulations
good luck with that grateful for finding
new ways of expanding and web
development business green foot for the
BTA hashtag because it makes me interact
more and focus more on Evans awesome
videos I love that grateful for almost
finishing my biggest web devel and
project so far it took me over 600 hours
but I'm getting there I love that
congrats man and give him front of my
one word hashtag improve interesting
interesting next we should cap TV oh I
skipped i skipped i skipped i skipped
the scroll on the hangouts is crazy fast
back back back back back back you guys
are chatting a lot ok Rishi grateful for
sir Evan see I might change my twitter
name who doesn't just talk to talk but
he actually believes in entrepreneurs
every single one thank you for that
reshape feeling the love I'm great I'm
thankful for my high school English
teacher Jeff Simmons or Simon Simon
sy Simon's three in today's national
coffee day it's national coffee day I
didn't know that I don't have a coffee
yet we have to get a coffee celebrate
national coffee day with Rishi what else
what else what else what else see you
guys are chatting what else we got what
else we got scrolling through welcome
new future builder welcome lie boo lies
has gratitude today because he's relaxed
and focusing on myself and being happy I
love that that's a good focus tommy Bowe
I'm happy for loving me self all right
Rishi's given a shadow to Alex Jackie
good morning Ivan has such a great team
that is that is a hundred percent true
mind-body I'm grateful for I I'm
grateful for I boogers because it keeps
waste away from my eyes and maintains
them healthy all right I'm liking it
Rhea much welcome back I'm grateful for
my phone it helps me communicate on the
go I love that my body people for my fan
because it keeps the mosquitoes away I
hate mosquitoes I'm allergic to
mosquitoes Boosh Boosh on hope I
pronounced that anyone from India I'm
not but may be grateful for our call
today much yet one of the hangouts is
with with much so tune in for that I'm
one of those connections haha veenu vanu
so people for my life right now that I
can create and shape and mold my future
the awareness to know that I can be
impact in I could be impactful in this
moment I love that cherry good morning
good morning share a new future build
their grateful for the rain a lot of
rain is raining across side the world
today grateful for the rain and the
music it creates as it hits interesting
the fact that it keeps our lands lush
and the look as it hits a puddle you
know what I have a I have a new
appreciation for rain after reading new
future builders comment there thank you
guys for that alright nine ten that's it
guys have an amazing day
gonna head off to twitch for our league
of legends business Q&A live stream with
rishi cup TV and jay rides you can check
us out there otherwise we back on later
today for three other hangouts one with
jen and two others after have an amazing
day if this is the last time i see you
then I hope you carry this gratitude
forward into some awesomeness into your
business continue to believe guys or
whatever you're on where it is and I'll
see you soon